that's right so let's go ahead and check
some words from keeve before we get into
this next match click on tapas these
were commonalities as Molly
yeah so coming into this that we are
starting with the top eight losers
matches finally and you know we're going
you guys just saw Keith he just wants to
fight everybody because of how strong
everybody is right but on the other side
he's gonna be going up against mehandi
Global's Shanshan pretty much the the
the bridesmaid man you know what both
incredibly solid and talented players
time and time again Keith you know
constantly utilizing criticize I think
what shut Chen is that this man knows he
knows that he's watched I'm excited for
him to pick listen listen I'm no
second-place Prince tonight this is my
night and a bus outs
crazy shenanigans I'm ready for the bag
of tricks okay I'm ready for three IgD
hours in a row okay no one will see it
coming I own a house I don't think
anybody would really be expecting that
from chanimal
no not at all he would never think one
of the things though that I didn't get
to talk about in the last time we saw
Shan Shan though is when his his mindset
right so obviously he plays sort of on
taste
one of the characters that everybody
considers to be a little bit lackluster
due to his inconsistencies sometimes
stuff just straight-up just rocks right
and that's just the nature of the thing
okay
so the way he looks at it is he has to
put all his heart and soul into
Cervantes he doesn't want to worry about
specifically winning the whole event he
just wants
that's possible with Cervantes and not
only that but if he see something
dropped he just he just have to thinks
of something on the flag he's like I'm
not gonna be mad about it I need to go
to a mixup this is just the nature of
the character so here we go heading into
Game one
we have chené chené versus Skokie let's
get it started
we've got the to the Beast stage wanna
bring out an opportunity also a wonky
wall this is the rematch from Evo Japan
first and second place is right here
coming in yeah you're talking about
spacing and respecting that has been
what keith has been doing so much over
the earlier matches right he was
definitely stepping back definitely just
artists and kind of the GI though from
Shin Chan oh right there IG d yards
gonna go over it there it is the fans
they get out so early that was actually
from downtown point okay no big
launchers which is by baby nice
interrupts right there from Shin Chan
he's just trying to lay out a bit of
pressure he doesn't like Eve to get a
chance to get started again right he
wants it he wants to overwhelm him and
he's doing exactly that nice knock on
the Loews though his few pets is looking
good
gunshot nobody's going to get CI nice
eyes if it's a launch want to see heck
oh my god [ __ ] [ __ ] on fire right now
that barely okay then I like this I like
this the spicy chené chené right now if
you get a free route that no brown baby
let's go
the final round possible final round
here sunshine right now looking for the
mix-up right after this one he's at the
wall and yeah you should be able to get
out again and get it do it that's one of
the powers of servants is he has that
unique wall throw of it I mean
especially on this particular stage with
the spot with a quote unquote small wall
and I do mean quote unquote because if
it's inconsistencies can allow for just
an instantaneous death a man doubled
down on them right there there's been
him with it twice to the studio that's
beautiful that was beautiful and I
definitely did a really strong job on
that Keith had such a hard time even
being able to move in that final round
look at this intensity dude look at this
intensity this is the intensity he means
that every match I'm not like like evil
Japan here the mix off a special
exception I mean he's always was as
intense response when he take to every
match very very seriously and he tries
to study any movement any option that
his opponent at all wow he was actually
able to punish the revenge attack he's
gonna get that big damage and a couple
of shots here we go mad working at foods
punching the side dude coming in the
camps oh yeah just put the fear gone and
decide setting a bunch and you can put
throw right here one more makes it blue
yeah I got no regio those are the pre
Kotak doesn't do a whole lot I got my
ankles broken a fire dances do that's
earning your dominance does the Alpha
right there when you change stances
about fear being punished for it well I
mean someone's face like that what the
thing is the shin-chan had no fear
though because you have so much health
left right so it didn't really matter
despite the fact that he did dad so
you've still got the round
okay let's get block Oh another 86
coming out at six against really strong
neuquén savant is one of his better ones
for sure okay five sectors blocking yep
that is punishment right there 8k comes
out it's very close to God Frank right
now but he's fighting back keep coming
back and all what a tough but no punish
on it does have one here to work with
though will he pop it yeah I don't know
he basically be losing meter if he if he
lost like losing a lot of bar that might
be a bit weird although he could with
punish using it just ten seconds but
[ __ ] who does not have a lot of help
breaks it yeah he's just and all by
gobbler easy a comes out he's actually
gonna be able to get enough damage two
feet up on the timer and get the kill oh
you boys Chechens delay against basic GI
is dead that W I like that two rounds up
clean in this it was a level breeze GI
so he wanted to make he think he could
read GI to stop him but no times right
there two bars on oh my god chef Chad
was clean through that so fancy Mike
look at this man three times he said
don't be on my stage this is my catwalk
let me strut let me strut he did a real
good job of recognizing every place that
he possibly was to set up those ring
outside he got he got a multitude of
them honestly and like Shanshan
dude that that was a completely
different way than he played against the
courts my opinion do you know what
though keep plate phenomena in general
he always does
time and time again so talented so
incredible every single event and you
know what you know even even being
eliminated to see that kind of run
consistently from every event has been
incredible so you know shoutouts to
France as well unfortunately